Speaker 1: All right, let's get into the mailbag
info at David Pakman dot com info at David
Pakman dot com info at David Pakman dot com.
Keep them polite, keep them quick, keep them
substantive.
And maybe it'll make the show or some people
try other approaches.
Let's start with our first email today from
KUNE.
I think it's pronounced Trump Your Podcast.
I wonder if you would be so kind as to tell
me who in the Democratic Party is paying and
how much?
Nobody from the Democratic Party is paying
me anything.
George Soros is not paying anything.
The Klaus Schwab is not paying and none of
them are paying anything.
We exist thanks to our audience, our viewers,
through a number of revenue sources, including
membership and YouTube ads, Facebook ads.
You do these types of things.
All right.
So whoever you think is paying us, they are
not unless you're talking about our audience.
But thank you for asking.
Rebecca wrote in.
Rebecca says, Please take down your video.
Biden Making Fun of Trump for COVID 19 Experience
Piece.
You can't trump fat.
You are not fat and only fat people can call
other people fat.
Then it's okay.
Skinny man, please don't show my email address.
Thank you.
Call me Mona.
Well, listen, it's not about me calling people
fat.
It's about Trump is obviously lying about
his height and weight.
And when we think about your ability to deal
with something like COVID, one's weight and
condition is a big factor in determining,
you know, what is going to be a more or less
likely outcome.
And Donald Trump is obese.
I mean, it's not it's not a pejorative.
He's he's just obese.
It's all it is.
All right, Rebecca slash Mona, we are not
taking the video down.
The video is staying up.
Thank you very much.
We will manage the YouTube channel as we see
fit.
Theresa from San Francisco wrote in with a
question about Anthony Fauci.
Theresa says, Hi, David.
You mentioned recently that elements in the
Republican Party are gearing up to investigate
Dr. Fauci's handling of the pandemic.
If they retake the House and or Senate in
the midterms, if this happens, do you think
it would be possible for President Biden to
pardon Dr. Fauci preemptively or otherwise?
Listen, the answer is yes.
There's two issues here that I think about
when I hear, oh, just pardon Fauci preemptively
to protect him.
Number one, Republicans will go nuts.
Absolutely nuts.
They will treat it as if Trump had preemptively
pardoned Don Jr.
Even though the circumstances would be completely
different.
Don Jr.
May genuinely have been involved in crimes.
Dr. Fauci is a public health official who
conspiracy theorists and extremists have created
a vendetta against.
So one is the Republicans would go so crazy.
Who knows what would happen?
And number two, it would be a really, really
sad commentary on the state of the country.
And we know the state of the country is in
the toilet, but it would be a really sad commentary
on the state of the country.
For a president to have to preemptively pardon
a career public health official who is over
80 and is retiring because of the rabid attackers
from the American right.
It would just be such a sad situation.
But yeah, I mean, Biden could do it.
I hope it really doesn't come to that.
Todd wrote in about Trump rallies.
Todd asks, Have you noticed it's the same
black guy in the background of all Trump rallies?
I only watch snippets.
I like that.
That's beautiful snippets of his rallies when
replayed on shows like yours.
And I've seen the same guy in the background
at all his rallies, meaning that guy is traveling
to all his rallies being paid to attend.
So there's two different things going on.
I know the guy that Todd is talking about.
I think that that guy is part of the group
Blacks for Trump and it's everything about
it is very unclear.
We just we don't know about it.
We don't want to offend anybody.
We don't want to dismiss anyone's activism
or anything.
But there's something very odd about the entire
Blacks for Trump group.
They have almost no presence online except
for one website, which is just.
Very strange rants.
We don't really know what to make of it.
It's all very, very weird.
But that's one thing separate from that is
the reality that like many Republicans, Republicans
have very low support from from black Americans.
Republicans love to put the black folks right
on the stage behind them to make the crowd
appear more diverse than it actually is.
So it wouldn't be shocking if, absent a natural
black crowd, the Trump campaign, the Trump
people had some friends of the campaign, of
friends of Trump who they would fly around
so they would have black people on the stage.
It's mere speculation.
I want to be clear.
I'm not saying that's going on.
I'm just saying it wouldn't really surprise
me.
Next.
Email is from Sean about Republican indoctrination.
Sean says, Sir, if you want to see some truly
disturbing Republican indoctrination.
Look at Prager, you kids.
It pisses me off that the American right claims
that schools are brainwashing our kids to
be communists when they talk about how they
want patriotic education.
Give me a break.
Sincerely, Sean from Minnesota.
100%.
They say now they are, quote, teaching transgender
to our kids to indoctrinate them.
They are pushing puberty blockers on kids
much too young to even be near puberty.
Why would they do that?
Doesn't make sense.
They are pushing kids to be gay.
They are pushing kids to be trans.
College is liberal indoctrination.
They're making them communists.
They're making them socialists.
They're making all this different stuff.
We would never do that.
And then you look at the learning about Trump
for kids, stuff that Mike Huckabee promotes.
You look at Prager, you kids, you look at
all of the different ways that they want churches
indoctrinating kids, not just into a religious
doctrine.
Most churches indoctrinate kids into religious
doctrine, but they want the churches indoctrinating
kids into a political doctrine as well, for
which, by the way, they should lose their
nonprofit status.
But they almost never do.
100% correct, Sean.
That is exactly what they are doing.
Dylan wrote in, Dylan says, Could the big
lie reduce voter turnout?
Do you think the big lie could reduce voter
turnout among those who believe it?
Trumpists who think the 2020 election was
stolen may not see any point in voting and
may not want to go out of their way to vote.
Interested to hear your thoughts?
100%.
In fact, last week Marjorie Taylor GREENE
said this.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE last week said she's
worried that the Trump people may not be that
enthusiastic about coming up to get out to
vote in November.
And then she parroted the big lie, which is
one of the reasons that Republicans sometimes
don't come out to vote.
The anecdote I mentioned last week was the
January five special election Senate elections
in Georgia.
Remember, there were these two runoffs.
January five, 2021.
And because Trump and Republicans spent the
two month period between the November election
and the January special elections, basically
just saying it was all stolen.
That almost certainly reduced turnout in January
and arguably cost Republicans control of the
Senate.
That's what's crazy.
They don't even seem to fully understand.
It's your narrative about the big lie that
is causing these problems for you to begin
with.
I hope they keep doing it.
I mean, it just hurts them.
Natalie wrote in about air fifteens.
David Did you see where they now have a new
gun?
The junior 15.
The J.R 15 marketed to kids.
We are in serious trouble.
But you knew this.
Love the show.
I did see the junior 15.
It is insane.
It is.
It's quite literally a rifle marketed to children.
It is the graphics on the.
I mean, everything about it is indicative
of an extraordinarily sick country.
I really don't know what else to say about
it.
It's we just have special rifles marketed
to children here.
It I'm without any further words to say.
Dominic from the UK wrote in and says, Hi,
David.
Whilst you and I understand Trump couldn't
get reelected without the backing of the Republican
Party, do you think his low intellect, coupled
with his high ego, could convince him to run
as an independent if he fails to get the Republican
nomination, thus ensuring a Democrat victory
in 2024?
I think this is a beautiful strategy.
The ideal scenario for the left would be Trump
runs for the nomination of the Republican
Party, but loses.
Someone else wins.
You know, right now, DeSantis is the lead
guy.
Someone else wins.
Trump.
Furious decides to run as an independent.
He siphons off 20% of the Republican vote
and ensures that the Democratic candidate
cruises to victory.
I think it would be absolutely fantastic.
He should be encouraged to do so.
I do think, speaking realistically, that if
Trump lost the Republican nomination in 2024,
his kids would be able to talk him out of
running as an independent.
I think they'd say, Dad, don't do this to
yourself.
You had a good run.
You're almost 80.
Screw them.
Let's go and do something else.
I do think his kids would be able to talk
him out of it.
Bobby wrote in with an answer to what is a
woman that he says would shut down conservatives?
Bobby writes, David, I keep hearing this question
in my mind is boggled that neither you, Katie,
Angie Brown, Jackson, nor any single sitting
Democrat or spokesman for the LGBTQ community
has given this simple response.
I majored in Poly Sci and I'm a freelance
writer.
Next time you're asked.
Or please tell your audience.
Here is your response.
All words have multiple definitions.
And to quote the Oxford Dictionary, traditionally
the preeminent dictionary on the planet, the
definition of a woman is a person with the
qualities traditionally associated with females.
This definition, 100% describes transgender
women.
And I've never heard a single Democrat use
it.
This would shut up anyone that asks.
Sorry, Robert.
It's almost quaint that you think that would
be like a woe mike drop moment.
If you say to them a person with the qualities
traditionally associated with females, they
would go like a vagina.
And you just are opening up a whole new can
of worms and a whole discussion.
I used to have these ideas like Robert, why
we go, This is so dumb.
Here's the incontrovertible Mike drop hammer
of an answer that'll have them on their knees
quivering, unable to respond.
And then I realize, wait a sec.
They always have a response.
That's not how politics works.
If you if you use this definition, a woman
is a person with the qualities traditionally
associated with females.
They would go.
Females have particular genitalia.
Boom.
It's over.
I'm not telling you that.
Their question what is a woman is isn't bad
faith.
I'm not saying any of that.
I'm just saying, trust me, that is not going
to have the powerful impact that you think
it will.
Info at David Pakman dot com.
Get your thoughts in questions, comments,
ideas, suggestions.
And we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Everybody else should make it themselves as
best.
Speaker 1: Such a good bonus show that I won't
even tell you what's on it.
Sign up at Joint Topics.